let me ask you
he said meaning
what's the meaning of this whole thing
what's the meaning of life you're the
perfect person to ask this question
i believe the meaning of life is for
human beings to grow in soul that's why
we're here and you can do that in
infinite numbers of ways but
you're supposed to return your soul like
more burnished and beautiful
then you got it i mean it's gonna have
you know
some nicks and cuts
but that's what it means to deepen and
grow it and you do that you do that
more than anything else you do that by
learning how to love i mean that's the
principle way i think that you do it you
know it's interesting because uh for a
human
the relationship
um
if you're a man of faith is with god but
it feels like love is so
ritually part of
human society that it's not just love
with of god it's love of each other
right yep there's no question about the
idea i mean
in judaism that was actually the great
innovation of the monotheistic idea
in pagan societies it was all about how
you treated the gods
monotheism said no god cares how you
treat each other
so
it's
in fact the mystics use the same kind of
word in hebrew de vekut which means
clinging that is used about adam and eve
about it says therefore a man will leave
his father and mother and davaok
with his wife
and davaok means cling so there is an
analogy there absolutely
yeah kind of i kind of think of human
civilization is that um there's that
movie march of the penguins and they're
all huddling together and cold yeah this
is this is fundamentally human is this
this um just this darkness all around us
of of uncertainty of cruelty of just
we're
we're
it's it seems like everything is so
fragile
uh and we're just kind of all huddling
together for warmth yes
and
that's all we got is each other
so uh we started with the the big
question of what has god ended with what
is meaning
uh
rabbi will be i've been a huge as i've
told you a huge huge fan of this for a
long time it's such an honor to you i am
really
so happy to be here and thank you so
much for the conversation
you